our last topic
for chapter one is complexity and that's
a that's again it's a very rough measure
of
how how long does it take on a computer
to carry out a certain operation
it's something we'll be talking about
throughout the course
okay so the way this works
is computers store a real number
in floating point format now in this
course you don't have to know what that
is
uh but what it is is it's it allows you
it doesn't
it doesn't represent the number exactly
but
it's very very close so for example it
wouldn't it wouldn't store the number
one third exactly as one-third
but it would store it as like .33333
with about 15
threes in there right which is for all
practical purposes
close enough okay now when you take a
basic when you ask a computer to carry a
basic
operation on two floating point numbers
like you ask it to add
or multiply them or divide them or
subtract
now that's called a floating point
operation or and the slang for that is
flops that's a flop a single flop is
adding two
numbers on a computer okay now when you
have an algorithm or an operation
and you wanna uh what you do
is the the complexity of it uh is judged
by simply counting up the total number
of flops
that it's that you're going to need to
do so for example
you might count the number uh both times
you have to multiply two numbers
add two numbers subtract or divide them
and you add up
all those numbers together and that
that's called the flop count
for your operation okay
now turns out this can be very grossly
approximated because
implicit in this is the idea that adding
two numbers comes at the same cost as
dividing two numbers
which is false it actually takes longer
to divide two numbers
however still this is just meant to give
you a rough idea
of whether carrying out an operation is
going to cost you is it going to be done
in way under a second
a second a minute an hour a day that's
that's really what we're aiming for with
this very crude estimate
okay now a crude approximation of how
long at times
it takes for a computer to actually
carry out that
that set of operations or that operation
is this it's the number of flops you
need
uh to carry out divided by the computer
speed and the computer speed is given in
uh flops per second okay so
you can see that flopsy divided by flops
per second gives you
seconds so it tells you it tells you how
long it's going to take in seconds now
this is very crude approximation we
would not we
certainly don't expect this to be even
like you know accurate within plus minus
20 percent and in fact you can even off
it'd be off by a big factor like a
factor of 10 or more but it it
it does distinguish between seconds and
hours that it can actually do
okay now a current computer is around a
can carry out around a billion flops per
second uh
actually my phone can carry out a
billion flops per second
so um and uh my laptop can do maybe 10.
um but fancier computers gpus for
example
you know graphical processing units they
can actually carry out even much more
than that uh they can some of them can
even
actually many of them now can actually
carry out
not just uh they can actually carry out
10 to the 12
uh flops per second that's a that's a
thousand billion
trillion flops per second that's called
a teraflop
per second computer okay um
so let's just do a quick example um and
uh let's say that you have an operation
that takes you know
uh 10 uh that that's going to require
you to do 10 to the 10
uh floating point operations that's a
lot right that's that's that's 10
billion okay and
so on a typical computer let's make it a
10 gigaflop computer but that means it's
also it can carry out 10 to the 10
flops per second and so we would guess
that that's going to take you about one
second
on that computer okay
so let's look at the complexity of
vector addition
inner product we can also look at scalar
vector multiplication
all right let's look at adding two
vectors so
when we add two vectors well it takes n
additions because you have to add each
x i to each y i and there's n of those
and entries so that's n flops total um
an inner product that's forming that's
calculating this
x 1 y 1 plus up to
xn yn okay well first you got to
multiply
all these pairs and there's n of those
you're going to have n multiplications
and then you're going to add them up now
when you add two numbers that's one
addition
when you add three numbers that's two
additions so when you add n numbers
that's n minus one additions
so you're gonna have to do n minus one
additions
and multiplications and altogether two n
minus one flops now
no one would ever give the minus one
because it's understood that this is
very crude and so people would always
say that
an inner product costs 2n flops
in fact a lot of people would even just
say n because we're not even shooting
for a factor of 2 in accuracy here just
n for the inner product now
incidentally this is interesting now you
can now we can say something about if if
one of these vectors is sparse
that can be a whole lot less for example
suppose x is sparse and y is not
x is sparse means that most of its
entries are zero now when i calculate
the inner product i don't have to worry
about those entries because all i'm
going to do is multiply x i which is 0
by y i
doesn't matter what y is i don't have to
do it so the only turns out the only
thing i actually have to do
is for every non-zero entry in x i have
to multiply that x i by the
corresponding y i and i have to add
those up
and so the complexity is is around this
it's twice the number of non-zeros
in x right so this is an example of why
you might be interested in or care about
sparse specters